hot breath speaking of your style and
your writing i'd love to get into that a
little bit
especially since you being more topical
driven and it can be tough
and there can be a lot of parallel
thinking especially on topics
that are more topical and current how
are you able to
create topical material that's unique to
you
well some things if you're going to be
top if you're going to do topical some
things you just do
um right away because the shelf life is
gonna be
short okay um
the entire trump presidency is that
because any stupid thing he says
he's gonna say something else a day or
two later
so you don't have time to polish those
jokes if it comes up you just throw it
out there
um when it comes to other things
what i look for i try to i try to look
for a point of view i haven't heard
someone else talk about
that's what i i and you can't always do
that i mean there is
parallel thought and there's so many
people out there that it's almost
i wouldn't say impossible it's not
impossible because you develop your own
voice
but when you're doing topical it's
you you have to understand there isn't
time to polish
every joke because some things are going
to come and go
and then other things are evergreen and
you just really get into what you think
about it so if i'm talking about an
evergreen topic or more or less
evergreen topic
like um racism or me too
or guns school shooting something like
that
then i get into my thoughts and my view
on it
and um and go with that you know uh
there are certain comics
that i can't watch too much because i'll
start doing them
um louis black is one
if i watch lou too much because i love
lou he's a friend and
and i'm a huge fan but if i watch lou
too much i'll start doing a lewis black
type rant you know and and i don't want
to do that
because that's his um there was a period
where i was running into a lot of and
this was
i i kind of started really getting into
social commentary after last comic
standing
but there was a period let's say in the
mid 2000s
that i found myself have early mid 2000s
having a lot of parallel thought with
chris rock and what i thought about that
was damn i must be on the right track
if i'm having the same idea as him i'm
doing something right
you know so but but the other thing is
and this goes back um to robin williams
i don't know if you heard those stories
but
yes when someone when someone
famous or big name does it
on tv or something then you got to let
it go because no one's going to believe
you thought of it but that's okay
because you'll think of something else
you know i'm not going to sit here and
argue
that i thought of a joke the same as
chris rock or i thought of it before he
did or
that there's no sense having that
argument
so i'll just do something else just keep
writing at the end of the day
yo yeah especially if you're topical you
know any the other thing is
jokes lead to jokes you know i mean so
when you're right if you're writing
something
and you're working on this idea then
you're like oh what about this
well that's now that's another idea and
then and this is the part we lose now
because there's really nowhere to
perform
you'll do it on stage and
people will laugh at something you
didn't realize they were going to laugh
at
so so you were aiming this way for the
joke and they laughed at something over
here
now when you're new you get mad and you
want to make your joke work
but once you learn some [__] then you're
like oh shut up let them laugh at that
let's see what's over there you know so
it happens different ways and when
you're thinking of topical material
um what is your process in terms of like
do you hear
something and your sense of humor is
almost like a spidey sense to where like
that topic is worth exploring verse that
topic isn't really worth exploring like
how do you put it through the filter of
like what's going to be worth the time
to write material about no i go it's
what makes me
laugh i'm a news junkie
i i well you got to trust yourself right
because as a comic
remember when you go on stage what
you're doing is you're showing the crowd
the world through your eyes
right that that's what the funny is you
get them to see it through
something they look at every day
suddenly you say it and they're like oh
i never thought of that and it's funny
like that's the underlying
process right so if it makes me laugh
then i go with it now as i was saying
i'm a news junkie
so i read a lot of news i read different
news
sources different stories and things
come up
and um over time and
and again this is why comedy takes time
to get good at
i learned to trust myself
so i'm not testing if it's funny when i
talk to the crowd because
i fee i believe i'm confident that i
know what's funny
and and confidence is part of it if you
deliver it confidently
then the crowd gets it i always say like
when people talk about
certain words certain topics like ooh
you can't talk about that
and uh and i don't know where i learned
this but it's really true
if you're afraid to say it they're
afraid to hear it
[Music]
that just gave me again as long as
you're not afraid to say it
as long as you're not afraid to say it
it's okay but if you're worried who can
can i
say this like no then they can't hear it
so
that's when you come to jokes about
topics that the crowd
may not be ready for you know dude
i have interviewed over 200 comedians
that is one of my
favorite quotes if you're afraid to say
it they're afraid to hear it
oh my gosh yeah that's a mic drop
all right i'll tell you where that comes
up that comes up now
politically right because people will
say to me oh
do you do that joke in the south would
you do that joke in a red state
i'm like hell yeah i don't give a [__]
so they're gonna you know and
and the other thing is the really
hardcore conservatives never come to
comedy shows because they have no sense
of humor
but uh
but yeah i'll say it because it's it's
you know what am i going to change my
act every city i go to so i don't hurt
anybody
you know it's ridiculous exactly so
let's let's get into the
the viewer questions here now oh man
that gave me the that gave me the
shivers right there that's a
that's a winning quote right there i've
never said the shivers before either i
don't know why i decided to
break that one out on this q a someone
just said hell yeah though i'm re says
hell yeah on
that so yeah that's that's gold breath